good morning John so since being
diagnosed with cancer I've noticed that
people's primary concern is that it
kills people which makes sense and just
like apparently the primary celebrity
concern is their net worth when you type
in the name of a cancer one of the first
autocompletes is going to be survival
rate but cancer survival rates it turns
out are even more complicated than
Celebrity Net worths so I wanted to talk
a little bit about it so that maybe we
can occupy like more of the correct
space of uncertainty when it comes to
this stuff because unfortunately there
is a lot of that and also maybe a tiny
bit of having a slightly healthier
relationship with mortality which isn't
easy so yeah this video is going to have
conversations about death and disease
including my own so if you're not in the
mood for that that's fine and I put a
link in the video description to a
wonderful video about electric car brake
lights which I love now your first
thought might be this shouldn't be very
hard just tell me how many people get
the disease and how many people die from
the disease and then I'll know how
likely it is to the disease is going to
kill that person and you can do this you
can crunch this number yourself it's
just that it's not that useful but it is
interesting to look at why it's not that
useful so let's do it in the US every
year about 9 000 people get Hodgkin
lymphoma or Hodgkin's lymphoma the
jury's out it's officially Hodgkin it
used to be called Hodgkin's Disease
anyway every year in America 9 000
people get this disease about 900 die of
it so there you go boom your statistic
what do you want more than that 10 of
people who get Hodgkin's are killed by
but that statistic does not contain a
lot of very important information for
example it could be that a lot of those
people have had HL for 30 years before
they died and dying of a disease one
year after diagnosis is very different
from dying of a disease 30 years after
diagnosis also if people are dying 20 or
30 years after diagnosis those people
had treatments that are 20 or 30 years
old which are much worse than treatments
we have today also individuals in that
population are very different from each
other Hodgkin's is actually like a
bimodal distribution with young people
and old people getting it it's actually
pretty weird weird that I got it because
I'm in the middle and people in their
70s or 80s are gonna have a worse
prognosis than people in their 20s if
only because they're less interested or
able to sort of do a lot of really
intensive chemotherapy and also people
who get Hodgkin's lymphoma are more
likely to die of things that aren't
Hodgkin's lymphoma both because of the
cancer and the treatment people who have
had Hodgkin's lymphoma are more likely
to die of heart disease lung disease
other cancers so to correct for a bunch
of those things and also for a couple
other reasons but still giving you like
not that much information overall we
tend to use something called The
Five-Year survival rate it's mostly a
thing to sort of help patients
understand where they're at really
quickly with a very simple statistic and
it's obviously not perfect because like
what about the sixth year like I'm not
concerned about whether this person
makes it five years are they gonna be
okay I just want to know if they're
gonna be okay there's like three reasons
why we use this and they're all pretty
good so I'm okay with us using it first
now this isn't true for all cancers but
it is true for some if you make it five
years you're likely to make it six and
five years is an amount of time that is
like a lot of life so we're just sort of
saying this is the likelihood that this
person is going to have a lot of life
left second if you start to look at
10-year or especially like 15 20 30 year
survival rates the data start to become
entirely useless because even with a
five-year survival rate you are only
looking at people who got diagnosed at
least five years ago in cancer
treatments and prognosis has gotten
better in just those five or six or
seven or eight years if you're looking
at 10-year survival rates then those
people were diagnosed more than 10 years
ago 15 20 years survival rates there's
just not it's not going to be Apples to
Apples compared to a person who was
diagnosed today and last you want a
valuable piece of information to get
across really quickly in that moment
that people will understand clearly and
the percentage of people that are alive
inside five years is very understandable
clear thing that tells people the most
important thing that they kind of want
to know right now but obviously there's
some imperfections here and there are
two things that are actually adjusted
for and you can adjust for them fairly
easily there's a website that I've found
that like I don't when I Google it I'd
ever find this but it's cancer
survivalrates.com and it just does a
good job of uh taking in like three
pieces of information and telling you
one two three five and ten I think your
survival rates and those pieces of
information are the kind of cancer the
stage that it is at and the age of the
person and those are the main important
things now some cancers also have like
the different kinds of cancer you can
click Little Boxes however even there
there's a bunch of information that
you're not getting for example people
who have Hodgkin's lymphoma who live for
five years who are still alive five
years later are very likely to never
relapse they will probably die at a
fairly normal age of some other thing on
the other hand people with chronic
lymphocytic leukemia are just as likely
to be alive in five years but are very
unlikely to not have that disease
anymore and there's lots of variation
here like some cancer is at certain
stages you're very likely to be alive at
five years but very unlikely to be alive
at 10 years at least with current
technology I don't think that we know
this enough but different cancers are
different diseases they are completely
different diseases with different
progressions different prognosis
different treatments and that makes it
so that statistics like these where
we're trying to find a piece of
information that can sort of be like a
consistent definition across a bunch of
different cancers just aren't going to
contain as much information as we
imagine them to or as we would like them
to and so now at this point in the video
we have to make a distinction between
like the two reasons a person would be
watching this video One is because
someone that you know about or that you
know a little bit or a celebrity has
cancer and you want to know what all
this means and for that like you're just
not gonna know there's gonna be so much
information that you are not going to
have and then there are people who are
watching because they or someone that
they love and that they're going to be
part of giving care to is has cancer and
there is going to be a bunch more
information heading your way or you
already have it or it's going to come
slower than you'd like but there will be
a bunch of information you're going to
know the stage of the cancer which is
basically a way of defining honestly
like
almost a different disease like cancers
at different stages are basically
different diseases they're treated
differently they have much different
prognoses you might also and this isn't
always the case but you might also know
the grade of your cancer which is how
aggressive your particular cancer is
active and some staging is just like one
two three four but some staging is
different from that like HL there's a
thing called bulky disease where you'd
put like a an X next to it if you have
bulky disease and then also there's like
a symptoms and there's b symptoms and if
you have b symptoms in bulky disease
then you could be stage 3bx I have stage
2A with no X which is great but like
that's more in the weeds than you're
gonna get with your average celebrity
cancer announcement when you start to
get into when you're actually like in it
is that like survival rate is one piece
of the prognosis and there are a lot of
other pieces of the prognosis which
include like the treatment and how that
you're going to respond to the treatment
are you gonna like live through that the
kinds of support you're gonna need as
far as like more more robust pieces of
information with regards to survival
that you might get there are two
statistics that you might hear about
there is the rate of disease free
survival so maybe at five years what's
the disease free survival rate and that
is people who not just are alive but
also don't have any signs of the cancer
in their body now that doesn't mean
they're not going to relapse but it is
good like if you're talking at all about
the disease-free survival rates then
that's a good sign for your cancer
there's also something called
progression-free survival and that's
when the person is both alive and their
cancer has stopped progressing it's no
longer spreading more throughout the
body that's something that we're talking
about more now that we're treating some
cancers especially in older people as
chronic diseases like we're not trying
to totally cure them because the
treatment would decrease the quality of
life of the patient so much it's not
worth it or it could even lead to the
possibility of them dying from
complications of treatment now you can
go deeper into the stats as far as
mortality gets like you could talk about
standardized mortality ratios which is
more of a useful thing in research
literature than it is in individual
lives because what it comes down to here
is that if there's like a 50 chance that
you're not going to be alive in five
years you're on one side or the other of
that like you're one data point you're
not a population study age and Stage are
not the only risk factors but they are
like basically the only ones that we do
a very good job of adjusting for in
these big like bulk studies but you and
your people know better like the actual
risk factors that this the individual
patient has you know better How likely
you are to stick to a really intensive
regimen of chemo which is a very
important part of people's prognosis and
you know more about your capacity to
advocate for the patient or for yourself
in an imperfect Health Care System these
statistics are useful I just don't think
that they contain as much information as
we think they do especially because it
tells you like one thing or another is
going to happen whereas conversation
with an oncologist about a sort of
prognosis it's going to be much more
full of detail about what to expect in
the future I think that it is extremely
important to talk to people who have
seen a number of folks go through
similar Journeys and that the doctor is
a good person for that and they should
be excellent resources for that and if
you feel like they aren't you should
talk to them about that or you know
every doctor should be fine with you
looking for a second opinion and that's
often the first step to getting another
doctor I talked to several different
oncologists and one thing I notice is
that they are very different from each
other and like what I vibed with isn't
about how bad of a doctor someone is
it's about me it's about what I need as
a patient and some patients are going to
want that like no-nonsense doctor who
talks about it like we're just gonna do
this and this is what we're gonna do and
we can do it and some patients are going
to want somebody who sits down with them
and looks at them in the eyes and feels
their pain with them and that's just a
different vibe and that's fine to want
one or the other of those things now at
the end here I want to share something
that I heard from a Creator on Tick Tock
who's also going through a cancer
diagnosis right now my name is Anne
Russell and she's a very smart thing
which is that a person who has an 85
chance of dying in the next five years
is a hundred percent alive now our lives
aren't valuable because we have a
guarantee that we're going to be here in
a certain amount of time our lives are
valuable because we're here now so
basically I think these stats are useful
but they are not as useful as we would
like them to be for two reasons first
because they just don't contain as much
information as it feels like they do or
as we would like them to and second
because I worry that people might see a
stat that says that someone's not going
to be alive in five years maybe and then
they would just start to treat them as
if they had already died which is very
bad and we shouldn't do that if you are
curious a person at my age with my stage
of Hodgkin's lymphoma has about a 94
five-year survival right and wildly
something like a 90 chance of
disease-free survival in five years
these numbers are so high for a bunch of
reasons one Hodgkin's cells are just not
good at repairing themselves and you
throw us to fit them and they die which
is great but also because of many
decades of careful and excellent work by
lots of researchers working with lots of
patients to whom I am will forever be in
debt thank you so much to all the people
who have been a part of making today the
best time in human history to get cancer
John I'll see you on Tuesday